porque es ridículo.
Sabemos que el cambio climático se suprime por todo tipo de razones.
Lo vi de primera mano cuando era profesora universitaria.
Lo vemos cuando los países se retiran de los acuerdos internacionales sobre clima
como el Protocolo de Kioto y el Acuerdo de París,
y lo vemos cuando la industria no cumple sus objetivos de reducción de emisiones.
Pero no es solo la información del cambio climático la que está siendo sofocada.
Muchos otros problemas científicos están oscurecidos por hechos alternativos,
noticias falsas y otras formas de supresión.
Lo hemos visto en el Reino Unido,
lo hemos visto en Rusia,
lo hemos visto en EE. UU.
y, hasta 2015,
aquí mismo en Canadá.
En nuestra era tecnológica moderna,
cuando nuestra supervivencia depende del descubrimiento,
la innovación y la ciencia,
es crítico, absolutamente crítico,
que nuestros científicos sean libres de emprender su trabajo,
libres de colaborar con otros científicos,
libres de hablar con los medios
y libres para hablar con el público.
Porque después de todo,
la ciencia es el mejor esfuerzo de la humanidad para descubrir la verdad
sobre nuestro mundo,
sobre nuestra propia existencia.
Cada nuevo hecho que es descubierto
se agrega al creciente cuerpo de nuestro conocimiento colectivo.
Los científicos deben ser libres de explorar
temas poco convencionales o controversiales.
Deben ser libres para desafiar el pensamiento corriente
y deben ser libres
para presentar verdades incómodas o inconvenientes,
porque así es como los científicos superan los límites
y superar límites es, después de todo, de lo que se trata la ciencia.
Y aquí hay otro punto:
los científicos deben ser libres de fallar,
porque una hipótesis fallida también nos enseña algo.
Y la mejor manera en que puedo explicarlo es con una de mis propias aventuras.
Pero primero tengo que llevarlos de vuelta en el tiempo.
Es a principios de 1900
y Claire y Vera comparten un cuarto en el sur de Ontario.
Una noche durante el apogeo de la pandemia de gripe española,
las dos asisten a una conferencia juntas.
Al final de la tarde, se dirigen a casa y a la cama.
Por la mañana, Claire llama a Vera
y dice que saldrá a desayunar.
Cuando regresa poco tiempo después,
Vera no estaba despierta.
Retira las cobijas
y descubre algo horrible:
Vera estaba muerta.
Cuando se trata de la gripe española,
esas historias son comunes,
las muertes a la velocidad del rayo.
Bueno, yo era una profesora de unos veinticinco años
cuando escuché por primera vez esos impactantes hechos
y la científica en mí quería saber por qué y cómo.
Mi curiosidad me llevaría a una tierra helada
y a liderar una expedición
para descubrir la causa de la gripe española de 1918.
Quería probar drogas de hoy en una de las enfermedades más mortales de la historia.
Esperaba poder hacer una vacuna contra la gripe
que fuera efectiva contra el virus
y sus mutaciones,
si alguna vez regresaba.
Entonces dirigí un equipo, un equipo de investigación,
de 17 hombres
de Canadá, Noruega, el Reino Unido
y EE. UU.
a las Islas Svalbard en el Océano Ártico.
Estas islas se encuentran entre Noruega y el Polo Norte.
Exhumamos seis cuerpos
que murieron de gripe española y fueron enterrados en el permafrost
y esperábamos que el suelo helado preservara el cuerpo y el virus.
Ahora, sé lo que están esperando,
esa gran recompensa científica.
Pero mi historia científica no tiene ese espectacular final de Hollywood.
La mayoría no lo tiene.
La verdad es que no encontramos el virus,
pero desarrollamos nuevas técnicas
para exhumar con seguridad cuerpos
que podrían contener virus.
Desarrollamos nuevas técnicas
para eliminar con seguridad tejidos
que podrían contener virus.
Y desarrollamos nuevos protocolos de seguridad
para proteger nuestro equipo de investigación y la comunidad cercana.
Hicimos contribuciones importantes a la ciencia
pese a que las contribuciones que hicimos
no eran las originalmente previstas.
En la ciencia, los intentos fallan,
los resultados no son concluyentes
y las teorías no funcionan.
En la ciencia,
la investigación se basa en el trabajo y el conocimiento de los demás,
o viendo más allá,
poniéndose sobre los hombros de los gigantes,
parafraseando a Newton.
El punto es que los científicos deben ser libres
para elegir lo que quieren explorar,
lo que les apasiona,
y deben ser libres de informar sus hallazgos.
Me escucharon decir
que el respeto por la ciencia comenzó a mejorar en Canadá en 2015.
¿Cómo llegamos aquí?
¿Qué lecciones podríamos compartir?
Bueno, en realidad se remonta a mi época como profesora.
Observé mientras agencias, gobiernos e industrias de todo el mundo
suprimían información sobre el cambio climático.
Me enfureció.
Me mantuvo despierta por la noche.
¿Cómo era posible que los políticos tergiversaran hechos científicos
en beneficio partidista?
Así que hice lo que haría cualquier persona horrorizada por la política:
me postulé para el cargo, y gané.
(Aplausos)
Pensé que usaría mi nueva plataforma
para hablar sobre la importancia de la ciencia.
Rápidamente se convirtió en una lucha por la libertad de la ciencia.
Después de todo, yo era científica, venía del mundo bajo ataque,
y había sentido la indignación personalmente.
Podría ser una voz para aquellos que estaban siendo silenciados.
Pero rápidamente aprendí que los científicos estaban nerviosos,
incluso tenían miedo de hablar conmigo.
Un científico del gobierno, un amigo mío,
lo llamaremos McPherson,
estaba preocupado por el impacto
que las políticas gubernamentales estaban teniendo en su investigación
y el estado de la ciencia deteriorándose en Canadá.
Estaba tan preocupado, que me escribió
de la cuenta de correo electrónico de su esposa
porque tenía miedo de que se pudiera rastrear una llamada telefónica.
Quería que yo llamara por teléfono celular a su esposa
para que esa llamada no pudiera ser rastreada.
Solo desearía estar bromeando.
Rápidamente pude ver con claridad lo que estaba sucediendo en Canadá.
¿Cómo podía mi amigo de 20 años tener tanto miedo de hablar conmigo?
Entonces hice lo que pude en ese momento.
Escuché y compartí lo que aprendí
con mi amigo en el Parlamento,
un hombre que estaba interesado en todo lo relacionado con el medio ambiente,
ciencia, tecnología, innovación.
Y luego vino la elección de 2015
y nuestro partido ganó.
Y formamos gobierno.
Y ese amigo mío
ahora es el primer ministro de Canadá, Justin Trudeau.
(Aplausos)
Y me preguntó si serviría como su Ministro de Ciencia.
Juntos, con el resto del gobierno,
estamos trabajando duro para restaurar la ciencia al lugar que le corresponde.
Nunca olvidaré ese día en diciembre de 2015
cuando orgullosamente estuve en el Parlamento
y proclamé,
"La guerra contra la ciencia ha terminado".
(Aplausos)
Y he trabajado duro para respaldar esas palabras con acciones.
Hemos tenido muchos éxitos.
Todavía hay más trabajo por hacer,
porque estamos construyendo este cambio cultural.
Queremos que los científicos del gobierno hablen con los medios, con el público.
Llevará tiempo, pero estamos comprometidos.
Después de todo, Canadá se ve como un faro para la ciencia a nivel internacional.
Y queremos enviar este mensaje:
"No te metas con algo tan fundamental
tan precioso, como ciencia".
Entonces, para el Dr. Bothwell, para Claire y Vera,
para McPherson y todas esas otras voces,
si ven que la ciencia está siendo sofocada, reprimida o atacada,
hablen alto.
Si ven que los científicos están siendo silenciados, hablen alto.
Debemos hacer que nuestros líderes rindan cuentas.
Sea ejerciendo nuestro derecho al voto,
sea escribiendo un artículo de opinión en un periódico
o iniciando una conversación en las redes sociales,
es nuestra voz colectiva la que garantizará la libertad de la ciencia.
Y, después de todo, la ciencia es para todos,
y conducirá a un futuro mejor, más brillante y audaz para todos nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)